This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. Have you ever had the experience of going to a party or office get together and meeting someone with the same name? The same birthday. Maybe you've gone on vacation to some far-flung locale and met someone who lives down the street from you. Many of us are drawn to coincidences like this. They make us wonder, how would the world that that happened? What does it mean? Today we explore our deep fascination with these moments of serendipity. New
这里是《隐秘的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。你有没有过这样的经历：去参加派对或办公室聚会时，遇到了一个跟你同名的人？或者生日相同。也许你曾去某个遥远的度假胜地旅游，却遇到了一个就住在你家街对面的人。我们当中的很多人都被这样的巧合所吸引。它们让我们不禁想知道：发生这种事的几率到底有多大？这究竟意味着什么？今天，我们将探讨我们对这些奇遇时刻的深深着迷。最新
research suggests they reveal important things about how our minds work and they have a far more powerful effect on our lives than most of us imagine. A couple of months ago we asked hidden brain listeners to share coincidences that they had experienced. Lots of people called in with amazing stories. Within those stories, we found two that themselves formed a coincidence. So, I was a student at the University of Rhode Island and we were in this writing class. This is Amanda Birch.
研究表明，它们揭示了关于我们大脑运作方式的重要信息，并且对我们生活的影响远比我们想象的要强大得多。几个月前，我们邀请《隐秘的大脑》听众分享他们经历过的巧合。许多人打来电话讲述了令人惊叹的故事。在这些故事中，我们发现了两个本身就构成巧合的故事。当时我是罗德岛大学的一名学生，我们在一节写作课上。这是阿曼达·伯奇。
She was talking to the teacher of her writing class and the teacher mentioned that she lived in a small town in Vermont. The same small town it turned out where Amanda's mother had grown up. The teacher asked Amanda what her mother's maiden name was and Amanda told her. She just kind of dropped through pen and she goes, you're not going to believe this but I live in the house where your mother grew up. The other listener who called us was Sarah Toproth. She called us on a scratchy phone line from Paris. Sarah is an American but has been living in France for several years. She was at a house party and someone there told her that there was another American in
她当时正在和写作课的老师聊天，老师提到她住在佛蒙特州的一个小镇上。而事实证明，那是阿曼达的母亲长大的同一个小镇。老师问阿曼达她母亲的婚前姓氏是什么，阿曼达告诉了她。她差点把笔掉在地上，然后说道：“你绝对不会相信，但我住的那栋房子就是你妈妈长大的地方。”另一位给我们打电话的听众是莎拉·托普罗斯。她从巴黎用一条杂音很重的电话线给我们打了电话。莎拉是个美国人，但在法国已经住了好几年。她当时正在参加一个家庭派对，派对上有人告诉她，现场还有另一个美国人。
the room. So she went over to say hello. They started talking and... So it turns out that this girl that I met at this house party in Paris grew up in the exact same house in Pichipsey, New York as my father. What are the odds? We thought we might find out. This week we'll talk about the mathematics of coincidences. That particular kind of coincidence, meeting an acquaintance or somebody you're familiar with, in a very strange place, I would say perhaps 80% of all the coincidences I've heard, fold into that category. And we'll explore why we are drawn to coincidences and what our fascination with them can tell us about the human mind.
于是她走过去打招呼。他们开始聊了起来……原来我在巴黎这个派对上遇到的这个女孩，她长大的房子跟我父亲在纽约州波基普西市的房子一模一样。这几率有多大？我们觉得可以探究一下。本周我们将探讨巧合的数学原理。这种特定类型的巧合——在非常陌生的地方遇到一个熟人或你熟悉的人——我想，在我听过的所有巧合中，大约有80%都属于这一类。我们还将探讨为什么我们会被巧合吸引，以及我们对巧合的着迷能告诉我们关于人类大脑的什么信息。
Whenever you see something that you can't explain the natural human instinct is to try to understand it, but that can also mean that sometimes we overexplain things. We're starting today with a story about Whisper. And just so you can understand this coincidence story, we're going to first explain what Whisper is and how it works. Whisper is an app that allows users to connect anonymously online. They can post messages or secrets, these are called Whisper's, and strangers can respond with their own Whisper's.
每当你看到你无法解释的事情时，人类的自然本能就是试图去理解它，但这有时也意味着我们会过度解释事物。我们今天要从一个关于Whisper的故事开始讲起。为了让你们能听懂这个巧合的故事，我们首先要解释一下Whisper是什么以及它是如何运作的。Whisper是一个允许用户在网上匿名连接的应用。他们可以发布消息或秘密，这些被称为Whisper（密语），陌生人可以用他们自己的Whisper来回应。
We've asked a few producers to read out some of these whispers. The messages are short about the length of a tweet and they range from the silly to the very serious. Some months ago the folks at Whisper got in touch to tell us a story about an interesting coincidence that happened on their site. Lauren Hudson is 27 and she turned to Whisperer at one of the darkest moments of her life. I was in a really bad relationship. There was a lot of domestic violence involved and I didn't really know what to do or how to reach out to people or how to talk about it so I used the app to connect with other women and to kind of vent and like find empowerment to get away from the person
我们请了几位制作人来朗读其中的一些密语。这些消息很短，大约一条推文的长度，内容从恶作剧到非常严肃的话题不等。几个月前，Whisper的工作人员联系我们，给我们讲了一个发生在他们网站上的有趣巧合的故事。劳伦·汉森今年27岁，她在人生中最黑暗的时刻之一转向了Whisper。我当时在谈一段非常糟糕的恋爱。其中涉及很多家庭暴力，我真的不知道该怎么办，也不知道该怎么向别人求助，或者怎么谈论这件事，所以我用这个应用来联系其他女性，算是发泄一下，并寻找力量来离开我当时在一起的那个人。
that I was with. Lauren was having trouble opening up about what was happening with her friends and family. I think I was scared to be completely honest. I think I had a lot of fear. And I didn't want like any police involved. I didn't want like, I didn't want it to turn into like this whole thing.
劳伦很难向朋友和家人敞开心扉讲述发生的这一切。我想我是害怕完全诚实。我觉得自己有很多恐惧。我不想牵扯进什么警察。我不想让事情变成那种大张旗鼓的样子。
But on Whisper she could be anonymous, she could seek support without all the immediate consequences. It was there in one of these threads that she started talking to a man. Lauren was touched by how much compassion he seemed to have for her, the complete stranger. It was almost as if he genuinely wanted to know how I was. Even though he didn't know who I was, and he knew that it was anonymous, and who knows who he's talking to, he just genuinely wanted to know if I was okay. He was in a town nearby, another coincidence perhaps, and they started exchanging messages. They connected immediately, decided to meet in person.
但在Whisper上，她可以保持匿名，她可以在没有所有直接后果的情况下寻求支持。正是在其中一个帖子中，她开始和一个男人聊天。劳伦被他对她——一个完全的陌生人——所表现出的同情心深深打动了。他几乎就像是真诚地想知道我过得怎么样。尽管他不知道我是谁，而且他知道这是匿名的，谁知道他在和谁说话，但他只是真诚地想知道我是否还好。他住在附近的一个镇上，也许又是一个巧合，他们开始互发消息。他们一拍即合，决定见面。
We got together and we went to Applebee's and we sat and we talked for like, I think it was like almost two hours that we just sat and talked. They became more and more inseparable. Lauren ended her unhealthy relationship and started dating this guy from Whisper, Eric. And everything was going great. But Lauren was a little nervous about meeting Eric's family. Eric had brought Lauren home to have dinner with them and the whole time she was anxious. Like my palms were sweating and I felt like really hot. I didn't know if like if it was going down well or if I was totally know? So I didn't know if it was going down well
我们聚在一起，去了Applebee's餐厅，坐下来聊了大概，我觉得有将近两个小时，我们就是坐着聊天。他们的关系变得越来越密不可分。劳伦结束了那段不健康的恋爱关系，开始和这个来自Whisper的男生埃里克约会。一切都进展得很顺利。但劳伦对见埃里克的家人有点紧张。埃里克带劳伦回家和他们吃晚饭，她全程都很焦虑。就像我的手心在出汗，我觉得浑身发热。我不知道事情进展得是否顺利，还是我彻底搞砸了？所以我不知道事情进展得是否顺利
or if I was totally blowing it. Like I didn't know what was going on. She was especially nervous about Eric's sister, Amanda. You know, I knew when I first met her the first couple of times that we hung out and stuff. I knew that there was a little bit of a distance there and I knew that every time I went over to, you know, hang out with Eric and his family, those walls would slowly break down.
还是我彻底搞砸了。就像我不知道发生了什么。她对埃里克的姐姐阿曼达尤其感到紧张。你知道的，当我和她第一次见面，我们一起出去玩的前几次，我就知道了。我知道我们之间有点距离感，我也知道每次我过去和埃里克以及他的家人一起玩时，那些隔阂会慢慢打破。
But Lauren was impatient. She and Eric were getting engaged. Lauren understood Amanda's attitude. She felt the same toward the girls her younger brother would bring home. Maybe I'll see them next week, you know, or maybe I'll never see them again, you know what I mean? So that was kind of like what I had in my head. a brother would bring home. Lauren wasn't going anywhere. She and Eric were getting engaged. Eric in fact had a flair for the romantic, bringing her roses, comforting her with her
但劳伦有些急不可耐。她和埃里克快要订婚了。劳伦理解阿曼达的态度。她对弟弟带回家的女孩也有同感。也许我下周会见到她们，你知道的，或者也许我再也见不到她们了，你知道我的意思吗？所以我脑子里大概就是这么想的。弟弟会带回家的那种。劳伦可不会离开。她和埃里克快要订婚了。事实上，埃里克很有浪漫情调，给她送玫瑰花，在经历艰难的一天后用她最喜欢的电影安慰她，而且他会把这一切都告诉家人。那为什么劳伦无法打破与阿曼达之间的坚冰呢？这段时间以来，劳伦仍然在使用Whisper。现在我用它不是为了寻求帮助，而是用它来帮助别人。这是我回馈社会的方式，因为当我需要帮助时，Whisper社区曾帮助过我。有一天，她开始和一个正在经历非常痛苦的分手的女性互发消息。我发了一条很长的消息，大意是说没关系，每个人都会经历心碎，外面还会有更多的人。
favorite movie after a tough day, and he would tell his family about all this. So why couldn't Lauren break through with Amanda? All this time, Lauren was still on whisper. Now I use it instead of me looking for help, I use it to help others. That's my way of giving back because the whisper community helped me when I needed them. One day, she started exchanging messages with a woman who was going through a very painful break-up. I sent a big message, basically saying that it's okay, everyone goes through heartaches and there will be many more people out there.
为了表达鼓励，劳伦向这位女性讲述了她自己幸福的恋爱关系。这位女性问劳伦她的未婚夫做过的最贴心的事情是什么。劳伦向她讲述了埃里克用她最喜欢的电影给她惊喜的那天。在我生日那天，我在工作很不顺利。就像那种你一醒来，从你双脚着地的那一刻起，所有事情都不对劲的日子。所以，我那天不想见到他。我当时糟糕透了。我只想待在家里的。
As a way to offer encouragement, Lauren told the woman about her own happy relationship. The woman asked Lauren about the nicest thing her fiancee had done for her. Lauren told her about the day Eric surprised her with her favorite movie. On my birthday, I had a really bad day at work. It was like one of those days where you wake up and just from the moment you put your feet in the floor, everything goes wrong. So, I didn't want to see him that day. I was just miserable. I just wanted to be home.
我只想上床睡觉。而他给了我一个惊喜，送了我这些美丽的鲜花、这些玫瑰花，还有《恋恋笔记本》，这是我历来最喜欢的、那种感人肺腑的爱情故事。劳伦讲完她的故事，等待着回复。在我把那个故事发给她之后，她的第一反应是，她就像是劳伦。回复。在我把那个故事发给她之后，她的第一反应是，她就像是劳伦。就像她，劳伦，我当时想，你怎么知道我的名字？你知道的，因为这全都是匿名的，而她说，我是阿曼达。阿曼达，埃里克的姐姐，正是她一直在现实生活中拼命想要与之拉近关系的同一个人。劳伦说，这个巧合改变了她与阿曼达的整个关系。
I just want to go to bed. And he surprised me with these beautiful flowers, these roses, and he had the notebook, which is my favorite like, sappy love story of all time. Lauren finished telling her story and waited for a reply. Her first response after I sent that story to her, she's like Lauren. reply. Her first response after I sent that story to her, she's like Lauren. Like she, Lauren, I was like, how do you know my name? You know, because it's all anonymous and she's like, this is Amanda. Amanda, Eric's sister, the very person she'd been trying so desperately to connect with in real life. Lauren says this coincidence changed her whole relationship with Amanda.
在网上随机结识并透露彼此的私密细节，让这两位女性感觉更亲近了。我们许多人都经历过这种巧合。你在上大学的第一天撞见了幼儿园的朋友，或者你在派对上遇到某个人，发现她就住在你爸爸在波基普西市的童年故居里。当这种巧合发生在我们的生活中时，它们感觉就像魔法一样。但正如任何数学家都会告诉你的那样，那些感觉不寻常甚至是不可能的事情，其实相当普遍。数学家约瑟夫·马泽（Joseph Mazur）深知这一点，但他起初并不想写一本会打破这种魔法的书。
Connecting randomly online and revealing intimate details about themselves, made the two women feel closer. Many of us have experienced these kinds of coincidences. You bump into your kindergarten friend, your first day in college, or you meet someone at a party and discover she lives in your dad's childhood home in Prokipsi. When these kinds of coincidences happen in our lives, they feel like magic. But as any mathematician will tell you, things that feel unusual or even impossible are actually fairly common. Mathematician Joseph Mauser knows this, but he was reluctant to write a book that would dispel the magic.
巧合是美妙的故事。我不想为了数学而毁了这些故事，因为，你知道的，我触及了人们对巧合的好奇心。不过到头来，约瑟夫还是写了他的书。这本书叫作《蹊跷：巧合的数学与神话》（Fluke: The Math and Myth of Coincidences）。书中充满了各种人们发现自己经历了极其不可思议的事情的故事。但约瑟夫·马泽说，如果你研究这个一段时间，巧合就会开始落入某些类别。我们从两位听众那里听到的故事，以及劳伦关于在Whisper上遇到她未来的小姑子的故事，基本上全都是
Coincidences are wonderful stories. I don't want to blow the stories in favor of the mathematics because, you know, I was hitting a nerve on coincidences. In the end though, Joseph did write his book. It's called Fluke, the math and myth of Coincidences. It's full of stories of people who find themselves experiencing things that feel so unlikely. But Joseph Mauser says if you study this for a while, the coincidences start to fall into certain categories. And the stories we heard from our two listeners, as well as Lauren's story about meeting her soon-to-be sister-in-law and whisper, are all basically
同一类型的巧合。而这本身并不是巧合。如果你把这些巧合分类，比方说分成十个不同的类别，那么那种特定类型的巧合——在非常陌生的地方遇到一个熟人或你熟悉的人。我可以说，在我听过的所有巧合中，大约有80%都落入了这一类别。约瑟夫·马泽说，这些巧合之所以让人感觉非同寻常，但实际上并没有那么非同寻常，是因为人们对我们以为自己实际认识的人数存在一个普遍的误解。
the same type of coincidence. Which in itself is not a coincidence. If you categorize these coincidences to, let's say, ten different categories, that particular kind of coincidence, meeting an acquaintance or somebody you're familiar with, in a very strange place. I would say perhaps 80% of all the coincidence is as I've heard, fold into that category. Joseph Meister says the reason these coincidences feel extraordinary, but actually are not so extraordinary, is because of a common misconception
人们认为他们的通讯录基本上就代表了他们认识的人，而事实证明，任何特定的通讯录大约只占他们在某种程度上实际认识的人的1%左右，换句话说，是一个邻居，或者是你在街上偶遇的人，但通讯录里的人只占你认识的人的约1%。因此，你偶遇熟人的几率比你想象的要大得多，因为你认识的人比你想象的要多得多。有时数学能帮助我们理解魔法。
about the number of people we think we actually know. People think that their address book is essentially the people they know, and it turns out that any particular address book is about 1% of the people they actually know in some way, in other words a neighbor, some of the bump into in the street, but the address book is about 1% of the people they know. As a result, the odds of bumping into someone you know are much greater than you think, because you know many more people than you think. Sometimes math can help us understand the magic.
比如赢得彩票这样的魔法，而且不止一次，而是好几次。一个名叫琼·金瑟（Joan Ginther）的女人就是这样。我想大概是在1993年，她在德克萨斯州彩票中赢得了540万美元。13年后，她再次赢得了200万美元。然后几年后，她又赢了300万美元。接着在2010年，她赢得了1000万美元。一个人四次中彩票的几率是多少？是的，这个几率是，我想有人做过计算，我也算过，几率大概是
Magic like winning the lottery, not just once, but several times. That's what happened to a woman named Joan Ginther. 1993, I think it was, she won $5.4 million in Texas Lotto. 13 years later, she won again $2 million. And then a few years after that, she won $3 million. And then in 2010, she won $10 million. What are the odds of one person winning the lottery four times? Yeah, the odds are, I think somebody made a calculation and I did too, that the odds are
18万万亿分之一（18 septillion to one）。18万万亿分之一。这简直不可思议。对于非数学家来说，“万万亿”（Septillion）是一个后面跟着24个零的数字。但约瑟夫·马泽说，我们其实问错了问题。换个角度想。如果我买了一张彩票，然后问：我中奖的几率是多少？我的几率非常小。但如果这个问题是：任何人中彩票的几率是多少？在一个拥有数亿人口的国家里，这个几率实际上要高得多。所以如果你稍微换个方式提问——不是问琼·金瑟四次中彩票的几率是多少
about 18 septillion to one against it happening. 18 septillion to one. That's incomprehensible. For those who are not mathematicians, a Septilion is 1 followed by 24 zeros. But Joseph Mauser says, we're actually asking the wrong question. Think about it this way. If I buy a lottery ticket and I ask the question, what are the odds that I will win? My odds are very small. But if the question, what are the odds that I will win, my odds are very small. But if I ask, what are the odds that anyone will win the lottery? In a country of hundreds of millions of people, the odds are actually much higher. So if you ask the question slightly differently, not what are the odds that Joan Guinter will
而是问任何人四次中奖的几率是多少，你就会得到一个截然不同的答案。我想我计算的结果是150万分之一，这跟万万亿分之一相差十万八千里。大约是500万分之一。这考虑到了世界上有成千上万个彩票开奖的事实。我的意思是，有很多彩票，其中许多都是大型彩票。所以，是500万分之一。虽然仍然不太可能，但并非不可思议。让它更合乎情理的是这样一个事实：大多数彩票得主在
win the lottery four times, but what are the odds that anyone will win four times, you get a very different answer. I think I calculated 1.5 million to 1, which is not anywhere near the septillions. It's about 5 million to 1. And that takes into account the fact that we have thousands of lotteries in the world. I mean, there are many lotteries and many of them are big-time lotteries. So, 5 million to one. Still unlikely, but not incomprehensible. What makes it even more comprehensible is the fact that most lottery winners don't stop gambling when they
中奖后并不会停止赌博。你会发现，几乎每一个赢得相当大一笔彩票的人都会把所有的钱或者大部分钱花在试图再次中奖上。约瑟夫·马泽说，琼·金瑟的情况可能就是这样。你赢了540万美元，你有了可以用来玩的钱，你用的是赌场赢来的钱（house money）。所以你是拿着赌场赢来的钱再去下注，她第二次中奖的几率比大多数人都要高，因为她有钱可以继续玩。她第二次中奖了，然后她手里有了更多的钱。你可以看到，第一次中奖和第二次中奖之间隔了13年
win. And you do find that almost everybody who does win a lottery fairly big time spends all that money or much of that money in trying to win again. Joseph Miser says this might have been the case with John Guinter. You win $5.4 million, you have a money to play with, you have house money. So you're taking the house money to bet again and her odds of winning a second time are better than most people because she's got the money to play with. She wins a second time, then she's playing with more money. And you can see the between the first winning and the second winning of 13 years
第二次中奖和第三次之间只有2年，第三次和第四次之间也只有2年。所以约瑟夫·马泽能够理解琼·金瑟身上发生的事情，但有些巧合简直违背了数学上的解释。约瑟夫跟我讲了他最喜欢的一个故事，关于19世纪的法国诗人埃米尔·德尚（Emile Deschamps）。法国诗人埃米尔·德尚。埃米尔·德尚在少年时期，遇到过一个名字非常奇怪的人，名叫德·福蒂布先生（Monsieur de Fortibu）。对方原来是一个来自英国的移民，德·福蒂布向他介绍了一种名为“普拉姆布丁”（plum pudding，英式圣诞布丁）的食物。这是一道非常地道的英国菜，在法国几乎闻所未闻。
between the second winning and the third, it was only two years and between the third and the fourth was only two years as well. So Joseph Mauser can wrap his head around what happened to Joan Gynther, but there are some coincidences that just defy mathematical interpretation. Joseph told me one of his favorite stories about a 19th century French poet, Emil de Champ. French poet Emil de Champ. Emil de Champ, as a teenager, he meets a man by the name of a strange name, Monsieur de Fortique Bou. He turns out to be an immigrant from England, and a faute bou introduces him to a plum pudding. It's a very English dish that's almost in her dub in France.
10年过去了，德尚路过巴黎的一家餐馆。窗户上挂着一块牌子，上面写着他们的菜单上有普拉姆布丁。但当德尚走进去时，却被告知最后一份普拉姆布丁刚刚卖给了一个坐在后排的绅士。服务员大声喊道：德·福蒂布先生，您介意和这位先生分享您的普拉姆布丁吗？
10 years go by, and Dixamp is passing a restaurant in Paris. There's a sign on the window saying that they have plum pudding on their menu. But when Dixamp goes inside, he stole the last of the plum pudding was just sold to a gentleman sitting in the back. The waiter calls out loud. Mr. DeFotinbou, would you be willing to share your plum pudding with this gentleman?
光阴似箭。德尚现在正和一些朋友参加一个晚宴。主人宣布将上一道不寻常的甜点。普拉姆布丁。德尚开玩笑说，赶来的客人中一定有一位是德·福蒂布先生。果不其然，门铃一响，德·福蒂布先生就被通报了。他走了进来。此时他已经是一位老人了。
Year has passed. DeChamp is now at a dinner party with some friends. The host announces an unusual dessert will be served. Plum pudding. And the champ jokes that one of the guests to arrive must be Mr. De Forti Bout. Well, as soon as the doorbell rings, then Mr. De Forti Bout is announced. And he enters. He's an old man by now.
但德尚认出了他。德·福蒂布环顾四周，意识到自己走错了公寓。他受邀去参加晚宴，但不是在这间公寓。我很喜欢这个故事，因为它是一个三重的巧合，并且带有一个非常美妙的故事元素。我的意思是，这太宏大了。这就是我喜欢听的那种巧合。约瑟夫·马泽，数学教授，同时也是
But the shamp recognizes him. Mr. De Forti Bout looks around and realizes that he's in the wrong apartment. He was invited to a dinner, but not in that apartment. I love that because it's a triple coincidence and it has a beautiful story element with it. I mean, that's so magnificent. And that's why that's the kind of coincidence I love to hear. Joseph Mazar, Professor of Mathematics, an author of
《蹊跷：巧合的数学与神话》一书的作者。稍后回来，我们将探讨巧合揭示了关于大脑的什么秘密。特别是，我对自己在生活中观察到的一种现象着迷。当我经历巧合时，它对我而言总是比对其他人更有意义。请不要走开。欢迎回到《隐秘的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。我对巧合非常着迷，可以连续几个小时听关于巧合的故事。但是，到底是什么让我们对生活中的这些时刻如此着迷呢？在芝加哥大学，心理学家尼克·埃普利（Nick Epley）认为他可能找到了一个答案。
Fluke, the math and myth of coincidence. When we come back we're going to look at what coincidence is reveal about the mind. In particular I'm fascinated by something I've observed in my own life. When I experience a coincidence, it invariably feels more meaningful to me than it does to others. Stay with us. Welcome back to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vidantam. I'm fascinated by coincidences and could listen for hours to stories about them. But what is it that so fascinates us about these moments in life? At the University of Chicago, psychologists Nick Eppley thinks he might have one answer.
他是《洞悉人心》（Mindwise）一书的作者。要理解埃普利对巧合的看法，我需要花点时间先向大家解释他更广泛的研究工作。埃普利的书探讨了我们如何解读其他人的心理状态和意图。这是一项非常有用的小技能，但我们有时会误用它。我们有时会将意向性赋予那些甚至没有生命的东西，尤其是当它们不同寻常的时候。例如，我们不会将晴朗的一天拟人化，但我们会给飓风起名字。卡特里娜、桑迪、安德鲁。飓风卡特里娜过后，新奥尔良市长说，上帝一定是对美国生气了。
He's the author of the book mind-wise. To understand how Epley thinks about coincidences, I need to take a moment and explain his broader work to you first. Epley's book examines how we read the mental states and intentions of other people. This is a remarkably useful skill, but we sometimes misapply it. We sometimes attribute intentionality to things that aren't even living, especially when they're out of the ordinary. For example, we don't personify a sunny day, but we give hurricanes a name. Katrina, Sandy, Andrew. After Hurricane Katrina, the mayor of New Orleans said, God must be mad at America.
这是一个新现象。几个世纪以来，人们一直将意向性归诸于自然力量。我们认为风暴、干旱和地震一定有它们自己的思想。这种用目的、意图或意义来解释行为的普遍倾向，通常是一种非常成功做法。
This is a new. For centuries, people have ascribed intentionality to natural forces. We think storms, droughts, and earthquakes must have a mind of their own. This general tendency to explain behaviors in terms of purpose or intent or meaning is often quite a successful thing to do.
事实证明，我们确实和具有意图、目标、远见、规划以及行动背后的意义的其他人类生活在一起。因此，总的来说，将这些倾向归诸于其他人的做法，是了解彼此的好方法。是解释为什么其他人在过去做了某事的绝佳方式，也是预测他们未来行为的好方法
Turns out we live with other people who do have intentions and goals and foresight and planning and meaning behind their actions. And so by and large, that tendency to make those kinds of attributions to other people is a good way to learn about each other. Is a good way to explain why other people did something in the past, to predict how they're likely to behave
但在未来，任何好工具的问题在于，有时我们会过度使用它。这就是当你在试图解释某种没有合理解释的事物行为时所发生的情况。一些随机事件、一些偶然的巧合、一些身体上的异常、或者突然冒出来、实际上可能背后并没有一个有意识的大脑在操控的天气模式。这就是为什么我们对那些以不可预测的方式移动的机器人如此着迷。我们发现，当人们得到对一个物体的描述、让它听起来不可预测时——比如你无法预料它的行动——正是这时，人们会描述或报告说它具有更多的心理状态。他们更愿意说这个物体有自己的思想，比如它有意图。我认为这完全不是违反直觉的，即它是一个有思想的存在。如果你看到，比方说，一个台球静止在桌子上，另一个球滚过来
in the future, but the problem with any kind of good tool is that sometimes we use it a little too much. And that's what happens in these cases where you're trying to explain the behavior of something that doesn't really have a sensible explanation for it. Some random events, some chance occurrence, some physical anomaly, some weather pattern that crops up that might not in fact have a mind behind it. This is why we are fascinated by robots that move in unpredictable ways. What we found was that when people were given a description of an object that made it sound unpredictable, like you couldn't anticipate its actions, that's when people described it or reported that it had more mental states. They were more willing to say that the object has a mind of its own, that it has intentions, for instance. And I don't think this is totally counterintuitive that is a mind. If you see, for instance, a billured ball sitting on a table, another ball comes along
撞击了它，然后那个球按预测的方向滚开了，嗯，你不需要任何解释来理解这个现象；但如果你有一个球放在桌子上，它突然开始随机乱滚，好吧，那你就得找个解释了。在这些情况下，有时人们会去寻找某种动因的内部，赋予它一个思想，也许这个球被附身了，也许有个恶魔在控制它，让它在桌子上移动。有时，当某种东西并不具备思想时，人们也会将思想归于它，但他们这样做是为了试图解释这个自主体（autonomous agent）内部到底发生了什么。当一个代理的行为表现得
and hits it, and that ball rolls off in the predicted direction, well, you don't need anything to explain that, but if you've got a ball sitting on a table, and it suddenly starts rolling around randomly, well, then you've got something to explain. And in these cases, sometimes people look to the inside of an agent, give it a mind, maybe the ball is possessed, maybe there's a demon controlling it, moving it around the table. Sometimes people attribute a mind to something when it's not there, but they do that as an effort to explain what's going on in this autonomous, in this autonomous agent. And they're more likely to do that when an agent behaves
有些不可预测时，他们就更有可能这样做。我曾经去一个朋友家，我的朋友有一个非常棒的游泳池，我曾经去一个朋友家，我的朋友有一个非常棒的游泳池，他放置了这个水下Roomba扫地机器人——暂且找不到更好的词来称呼它——用来清洁泳池底部。所以它就在泳池底部四处滚动，以一种完全随机的方式行进，对吧？所以它就运行几个小时。它在清洁泳池底部。我发现自己看着它入迷了，因为你无法预测它接下来会做什么，这让它比那些以高度可预测的方式移动的东西更有趣、更有生命力。完全正确。那种像机器人一样移动、非常可预测的东西，只是一台没有思想的机器；但当你的Roomba随机乱跑时，好吧，现在它好像有点想去那边了。现在它又想往这边挪。现在它意识到它
somewhat unpredictably. I was over at a friend's house and my friend has a wonderful pool and I was over at a friend's house and my friend has a wonderful pool and he had set this underwater room bar for the lack of a better term to clean the bottom of the pool. So it sort of rolls around the bottom of the pool and it goes in this completely random fashion, right? So it just runs for a couple of hours. It's cleaning the bottom of the pool. And I found myself fascinated just watching it because the fact that you can't predict what it's going to do next makes it just more interesting and more alive in a way than something that moves in a very predictable fashion. Absolutely. Something that moves robotically, very predictably, that is just a mindless machine, but when your room buzz going around randomly, well, now it wants to go over there a little bit. Now it wants to move over here. Now it realizes it
还没有清理泳池那边的那个侧面。随机行事的事务开始带有一点点思想的意味了。现在，人们可没疯。你不会觉得它就像是你妈妈，对吧？或者是正在打扫客厅的配偶。但它开始看起来确实更有思想了。事实上，Roomba就是个很好的例子，人们真的会给他们的Roomba起名字，你还可以买衣服来把它打扮起来。如果你在网上谷歌一下这个，你会发现各种各样的例子：人们觉得自己的Roomba可能比实际上拥有更多一点的思想。我想和你聊聊巧合这个主题，我想到了你和你的工作，因为我觉得，当一些不寻常的事情
didn't clean that side of the pool over there. Things that behave randomly start to get a little sense of a mind. Now people aren't crazy. You don't think it's like your mother, right? Or your spouse who's vacuuming the living room. But it starts to look just a little bit more mindful. In fact, their room wasas are good example people Actually do name their Rumbas you can buy outfits to dress it up if you Google this Online you'll find all kinds of examples of people thinking of their Rumbas having perhaps a little bit more of a mind than it really does I want to talk to you a little bit about the subject of coincidences and I thought of you in your work because it feels to me that when something unusual happens
发生在我们身上时，我们会停下来然后说：太诡异了。我刚才在书里读到这个词，周围房间里的某个人就提到了同一个词。这让你停下来抬头，就像我停下来看着那个水下的Roomba一样。完全正确。这是一个发生不寻常事件的案例。它是不可预测的，而你试图去解释它。你可以用许多不同的方式来解释这种随机的巧合。
to us and we stop and we say, that is weird. I was just reading this word in a book a second ago and someone in the room around me mentions the very same word. And it makes you stop and look up just like I stop and look at that underwater roomba. Absolutely. That's a case where something unusual happens. It was unpredictable, and you try to explain it. You can explain these kinds of random coincidences in lots of different ways.
我们可以把许多不同种类的因果结构套用在它上面。但其中一些涉及赋予它比实际更多的意义。这就是水下Roomba与巧合的关系。就像一个做出意料之外举动的机器人一样，巧合由于不同寻常而强烈要求得到意义或解释。即使根本没有模式，我们也会开始寻找模式。在心理学世界里，我最喜欢的一个例子其实是由我的博士导师汤姆·吉洛维奇（Tom Gilovich）和杰出的心理学家阿莫斯·特沃斯基（Amos Tversky）首先记录的一种现象。
There are lots of different kinds of causal structures we might be able to put on it. But some of them involve giving it more meaning than it actually has. This is what underwater rumbers have to do with coincidences. Like a robot that does something unexpected, coincidences cry out for meaning or explanation because they're out of the ordinary. We start to seek patterns even when they aren't any. My favorite example of this in the world of psychology is actually a phenomena first documented by my PhD advisor Tom Gilevich and the brilliant psychologist Amos Tversky.
这就是篮球场上的“热手谬误”（hot hand in basketball）。流传的神话是，在罚篮时，篮球球员会进入一种顺风顺水的状态。人们相信篮球运动员会手感火热，他们会一鼓作气，而他们刚投进一个球后，再进一个球的几率要高于他们刚投丢一个球之后。埃普利并不是说篮球运动员没有连续得分的爆发期（streaks）。他是说我们对这些连胜做出了错误的结论。让我们假设他们是一个优秀的投手，命中率为50%。
It is the illusion of the hot hand in basketball. The myth is that, when shooting free throws, basketball players get on a roll. People believe that basketball players get a hot hand, and that their times win their own, and the chance of making a basket is higher after they've just made one than after they've just missed one. Eplea isn't saying basketball players don't have streaks. He's saying we draw the wrong conclusion about these streaks. Let's imagine that they're a good shooter and they shoot 50% from the field.
这50%的概率会导致投篮结果出现比人们预期更多的“扎堆”（clumping）现象。人们预期50%的抛硬币概率会比实际情况发生更多更频繁的交替。所以当你在现实世界中看到随机性时，它其实看起来比实际情况更有条理。埃普利描述了一个展示这种现象的派对戏法。你也可以这样做。给派对上的每个人一张便签纸，让他们写下他们认为抛30次硬币会是什么样子。
That 50% probability is going to produce a lot more clumping in the baskets than people expect. People expect a coin flip of 50%, to alternate a lot more than it actually does. And so when you see randomness out in the world, it actually looks more ordered to you than it really is. Echelie described a party trick that demonstrates this phenomenon. You can do this too. Give everyone in the party a note card and have them write down what they think 30 coin flips would look like.
如果是正面就写H（Heads），如果是反面就写T（Tails）。然后，作为神奇的魔术师，你离开房间，让一个人上来实际抛30次硬币。这个人把实际的抛硬币顺序写在便签纸上，然后收集所有的便签纸——真实的和想象的顺序——并将它们混在一起。接着，身为魔术师的你回到房间，找出哪张卡片是真正的抛硬币结果。你辨别的方法是寻找那张
H, if they think it will be heads, T, if they think it will be tails. You then, as master magician, leave the room and you have one person come up and actually flip a coin 30 times. That person writes down the actual sequence of coin flips on a note card and then collects all the note cards, the real and the imagined sequences, and puts them together. You the magician then come back into the room and identify the card that was the real coin flip. And the way you do this is you look for the card
拥有最长连续相同结果的卡片。因为人们的想象并不认为50-50的概率会产生非常长的连续结果，所以人们想象出来的抛硬币结果会比真正的抛硬币结果交替得更频繁，这就是你如何从假卡片中辨别出真卡片的方法。我认为我们拥有的那种错觉——即随机性是交替出现的，或者比实际情况更具偶然性，即扎堆现象更少——也是引发其他现象的原因：我们在世上看到随机性时，会在其中看到比实际存在更多的可预测性或意向性。
that has the longest runs. because people's imagination doesn't presume that a 50-50 probability will produce very long runs and so people's imagined coin flips will alternate more than the real coin flip wheel and that's how you can identify the real one from the fake ones. And I think that illusion that we have, that randomness alternates, or is more chancey than it actually is, that there's less clumping is also the thing that gives rise to these other phenomena where we see randomness in the world, and we see more predictability or intentionality than actually exist in it.
当我们邀请听众与我们分享巧合时，许多人写信分享了发生在他身上的非常有趣的例子。让我感到震惊的一件事是，有时候一种巧合对你而言似乎比对其他人更有意义。例如，当我正在读一书，偶然看到一个不寻常的词，然后房间里的某个人就提到了那个同样的词。对我来说，这感觉像是某种征兆。书，偶然看到一个不寻常的词，然后房间里的某个人就提到了那个同样的词。对我来说，这感觉像是某种征兆。但如果我告诉你，我说：“尼克，你知道吗，这事儿昨天发生在我身上了，”你大概会说：“噢，当然，这种事大概每个月左右就会发生一次吧。”这完全是你遵循概率定律时所预期的结果。
When we asked our listeners to share coincidences with us many of them wrote in with really interesting Examples of things that happened to them One thing that I was struck by is is the sense that sometimes a Coincidence seems more meaningful to you than it does to someone else So for example when I'm reading a book and I come by an unusual word and then someone in the room mentions that same word To me it feels like it's a sign of something book and I come by an unusual word and then someone in the room mentions that same word. To me it feels like it's a sign of something. But if I would tell you I say, Nick, you know, this happened to me yesterday, you'd say, yeah, sure, that's going to happen once every month or so. It's exactly what you would expect if you believe the laws of probability.
你认为为什么巧合对我们而言比对其他人更有意义？这真是个好问题。其实我不知道自己是否见过任何研究证明过这种现象，但这让我觉得是一个非常引人注目的假设。我认为这很可能是正确的。我认为巧合之所以一开始看起来很有意义，是因为你正试图解释它们。
Why do you think it is that coincidences are more meaningful to us than to other people? That's a really good question. I actually don't know that I've seen any research that demonstrates that phenomena, but that strikes me as a very compelling hypothesis. I think that's probably likely to be right. And I think the reason why coincidences seem very meaningful in the first place is that you're trying to explain them.
你和我同时想到了“螺旋桨”（propeller）这个词。尚卡尔怎么会在我想着螺旋桨的同时也在想着螺旋桨，这到底是怎么回事？所以你正在试图解释这一点。你专注于刚刚发生在自己身上的那个事件。它对你具有个人的相关性。这让它产生了冲击力。但这也会让你变得有些短视。而我们没有考虑到的是，房间里的我们任何人当时都可能同时想到其他所有事情，这些事情对我们来说也可能显得很神奇。我们正试图解释这一件事，因为它对我们太有意义了。它刚刚发生在我们身上。其他人没那么容易变得如此短视，我认为，所以他们更有可能去思考其他可能发生在你身上的事情，
You and I both thought of the word propeller at the same time. How on earth could that be that Shankar was thinking about propeller at the same time that I was? And so you're trying to explain that. You're focusing on that event that just happened to you. It has personal relevance to you. That makes it impactful. But it also makes you somewhat myopic. And what we don't think about are all of the other things that any of us in the room could have thought about at the same time that might also have seemed amazing to us. We're trying to explain this one thing because it's so meaningful to us. It just happened to us. Other people are less likely to be that myopic, I think, and so there would be likely to think about other things that could have happened to you,
这会让他们觉得这件事没那么神奇。我们在节目中当然也经历过这种巧合，当时两位听众打进电话，分享了诡异相似的巧合故事。我向尼克描述了这两个故事，关于两个女性偶遇了这样的人：这些人后来被证明就住在女人们的父母长大的同一栋房子里。所以这些不仅仅是两个巧合。这是两个巧合，而且都发生在我们《隐秘的大脑》节目身上，这似乎真的非同寻常，尼克。怎么可能会有这种事，你得到了这两个完全一样的故事，这就是魔法，尚卡尔。你太神奇了。这其实就是我一直想听你说的，尼克，花了20分钟才让你说出口。最终我们不得不向概率定律低头，没有什么能解释这一点，对吧？尼克，我要谢谢你今天和我们交谈。好的，谢谢邀请我。
which would make it seem less amazing to them. We of course experience the Sarsals here at the show, when two listeners called in with eerily similar coincidence stories. I describe these two stories to Nick about women who ran into people who turned out to live in the very same house where the women's parents had grown up. So these are not just two coincidences. These are two coincidences that both happened to us at Hidden Brain, which seems Truly extraordinary, Nick. How could that possibly be that you get these two that are exactly the same as magic as what it is, Sean Carr. You're magical. That's really just all I wanted to hear you say, Nick, it's been 20 minutes to get that out of you. Eventually we have to give into the laws of probability there's nothing that can explain that right. Nick I want to thank you for talking with us today. Yeah, thanks for having me.
尼克·埃普利是《洞悉人心：我们如何理解别人的想法、信念、感觉和愿望》一书的作者。就在我跟尼克·埃普利谈完不久后，我接触到了一些新的研究成果，这让我对巧合有了截然不同的看法。是的，巧合确实能让人感觉充满魔力，它们也确实揭示了关于我们大脑运作方式的重要信息。但也有心理学研究表明，巧合实际上可以改变我们生活的方向。它们可以具有强大的意义。现在和我约会的女孩，我们俩同一天生日。这挺酷的。我的未婚妻和我确实同一天生日，这是我们在第二次约会时发现的。
Nick Eppley is the author of mind wise how we understand what others think, believe, feel and want. Not long after I finished talking to Nick Appley, I came by some new work that made me think about coincidences very differently. Yes, coincidences can feel magical and they do reveal important things about how our minds work. But there's also psychological research that shows coincidences can actually change the direction of our lives. They can be powerfully meaningful. The girl that I am dating now we have the same birthday. This is kind of cool. My fiance is real and I have the same birthday which is something we discovered on our second date.
起初，这些可能看起来像是司空见惯的巧合。两个人开始约会，发现他们同一天生日。但这些证据表明，这可能不仅仅是我们之前在节目中讨论过的那种巧合。拥有共同的生日似乎确实能将人们拉得更近。当我第一次去找一个新的发型师时，我们发现我们同一天生日，于是我们互称对方为“生日双胞胎”。结果我连续多年都去找那个发型师剪头发，甚至在她换了沙龙之后，甚至在我们搬家之后。
At first, these may seem like garden variety coincidences. Two people start dating, they discover they have the same birthday. But these evidence this may be more than just the kind of coincidence we've been talking about so far on the show. Having a common birthday seems to actually draw people closer to one another. When I first went to a new hairstylist, we found out that we had the same birthday and we called each other birthday twins. And I wound up going to that hairstylist for years even after she switched to runs, even after we moved.
我会开车40分钟去找她剪头发。有些人从共同的生日、甚至生日中的共同数字中看到了如此多的重要性，以至于他们根据这些模式来选择重要事件的日期。我的生日是10月27日，我的第一任丈夫，他的生日是9月27日，我们有机会在8月27日结婚。这简直是不需要动脑筋的决定。我们决定那样做。你刚刚听到这位女士，来自俄克拉荷马城的珍妮塔·克雷文斯（Geneta Cravens）说，她对有着相同生日的人的热爱已经超出了她的爱情生活。2月27日也是西奥多·罗斯福（Teddy Roosevelt）的生日，
I would drive 40 minutes to go get my hair cut by her. Some people see so much significance in shared birthdays or even shared numbers into birthdays that they select dates for important events based on those patterns. My birthday is October 27th and with my first test end, his birthday was September 27th and we had the opportunity to get married on August 27th. It was a no-brainer. We decided to do that. The woman you just heard, genetic cravingsven's from Oklahoma City says her love for people with the same birthday extends beyond her love life. On February 27th is also Teddy Roosevelt's birthday,
所以我一直对他在和他的领导力有一种亲切感。事实上，共同的生日并不是唯一能把人们拉得更近的东西。珍妮塔还发现自己会被那些碰巧拥有相同名字的人吸引。当我遇到另一个珍妮塔时，就会有一种自动的反应，比如“噢天哪，我真不敢相信我们同名”。然后碰巧我们连拼写都一样。我跟你说，我只遇到过两个名字拼写跟我一样的人，但我能说出他们是谁，而且我立刻就会产生一种心连心的感觉。这不仅仅是珍妮塔。
and so I've always felt a little affinity for him and for his leadership. Shared birthdays, in fact, aren't the only thing that draw people closer to one another. Geneta also finds herself drawn to people who happen to have the same name. When I meet another geneta, there's an automatic, like, oh my gosh, I can't believe we have the same name. And then it happens to be that we have the same spelling. And I'll tell you, it's only met two people who have the same spelling of me, but I can tell you who they are and I hope in an automatic concept. This is not just Genera.
我们所有人都受到研究人员所称的“内隐自负”（implicit egotism）的影响。木匠从事木工工作。面包师做面包师。屠夫做屠夫。请不要走开。这里是《隐秘的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。在希腊神话中，猎人纳西索斯（Narcissus）对自己的美貌如此着迷，以至于他爱上了自己在水中的倒影。现代心理学表明，我们每个人体内都有点纳西索斯的影子。
All of us are affected by what researchers call implicit ecotism. Carpenter is working in carpentry. Bakers working as bakers. Butchers working as butchers. Stay with us. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. In Greek mythology, the hunter narcissists were so enamored by his own beauty that he fell in love with a reflection of himself Modern psychology shows that we all have a little bit of narcissists in us
我们大多数人都喜欢那些让我们想起自己的人，无论是同名的人还是同一天生日的人。大多数时候，这种自恋是有趣且无害的，甚至可能是有益的，是良好自尊的表现。但有时，爱上我们自己或者那些让我们想起自己的人是有趣且无害的，甚至可能是有益的，是良好自尊的表现。但有时，爱上我们自己或者那些让我想起自己的人，可能会成为一个真正的问题。布雷特·佩尔姆（Brett Pelham）是马里兰州蒙哥马利学院的心理学教授。他研究一种叫作“内隐自负”的现象，这个概念认为许多偏见都是无意识的
Most of us like people who remind us of ourselves whether that's someone with the same name or someone with the same birthday Most of the time such self-love is amusing and harmless Maybe even beneficial a sign of good self-esteem But there are times when falling in love with ourselves or with people who remind us of ourselves is amusing and harmless, maybe even beneficial, a sign of good self-esteem. But there are times when falling in love with ourselves or with people who remind us of ourselves can be a real problem. Brett Palem is a professor of psychology at Montgomery College in Maryland. He studies something called implicit egotism, which is the idea that many biases are unconscious
我们大多数人都喜欢那些让我们想起自己的人，无论是名字相同还是生日相同。大多数时候，这种自爱是有趣且无害的，甚至可能是有益的，是良好自尊的表现。但有时，爱上我们自己或那些让我们想起自己的人可能会成为真正的问题。布雷特·帕勒姆是马里兰州蒙哥马利学院的心理学教授。他研究一种叫做内隐自负的现象，这个概念表明许多偏见是无意识的
and one very well studied bias was egotism, valuing the self favorably, protecting the self and so forth. And so we simply got the idea that there are several different things that at least to some degree reflect the preference for the self and an attraction to things that resemble the self. Like having an affinity for someone with the same birthday or someone with the same name, or even going into a profession that sounds like an echo of your name.
其中一个被深入研究的偏见就是自负，即积极地评价自我、保护自我等等。因此我们自然而然地想到，有几种不同的事物，在某种程度上至少反映了对自我的偏好，以及对与自己相似的事物的吸引力。比如对生日相同的人或名字相同的人产生亲近感，甚至选择一个听起来像你名字回声的职业。
So we originally looked at whether people named Dennis or Denise gravitate toward dentistry, but we learned pretty quickly that it's really hard to get data on those things. So there aren't great directories of medical professionals. There is a guy named Abel who was able to document, and I was a reviewer on this paper.
所以我们最初研究的是名字叫丹尼斯（Dennis）或丹尼斯（Denise）的人是否会倾向于从事牙医行业，但我们很快发现，要获得这些数据其实非常困难。因此并没有关于医疗专业人员的出色名录。有一个名叫阿贝尔（Abel）的人，他能够记录这些，而我是这篇论文的审稿人。
So now every time you say this, I'm going to jump in and say a guy named Abel who was able to do something. He was able to do a lot of things. He showed that people whose last name is Doctor or whose last name is the word lawyer, the name lawyer, gravitated toward those two professions. There are lots of other examples.
所以现在每次你这么说，我都要插话，说一个叫阿贝尔的人能够做成某事。他确实能做成很多事。他发现姓氏是“医生”（Doctor）或姓氏是“律师”（lawyer）这个词、即律师这个名字的人，会倾向于从事这两个职业。还有很多其他的例子。
Brett looked at a massive database of millions of Americans, names from the recently released 1940 census, to examine if they were brought patterns, like carpenters working in carpentry, bakers working as bakers, butchers working as butchers, miners working as miners, maisens working as maisens. So we looked at every surname there is currently the top 2000 surnames that happens to be a career name and we looked at all of them. They're 11 of them that are pretty common. I just listed a few. And for every single surname in the 1940 census with something like a I think it was 130 million people, we were able to show that for every single surname there was at
布雷特研究了一个包含数百万美国人的庞大数据库，这些名字来自最近发布的1940年人口普查，旨在检验是否存在普遍的规律，比如木匠从事木工工作，面包师从事烘焙，屠夫从事屠宰，矿工从事采矿，石匠从事石工。因此，我们查看了目前排名前2000的、恰好是职业名称的所有姓氏，并对它们全部进行了研究。其中有11个是相当常见的。我只列举了几个。在1940年人口普查中，对于每一个这样的姓氏，涉及大约——我想是1.3亿人，我们能够证明，每一个姓氏都存在一种
least a weak tendency for people to gravitate toward careers that perfectly matched their last names. So the obvious thing to say of course is that the reason you have a slightly larger number of carpenters, B carpenters, is that the name carpenters probably originated from families who were in carpentry. And so there is some kind of ancestral connection to the profession that is driving both the names and the choices. Quite possibly, but if you do the math, you pretty quickly see it gets to be a pretty tiny percentage of people. So if you assume that even over 10 generations,
至少是微弱的倾向，即人们倾向于选择与他们姓氏完美匹配的职业。所以显而易见的一种说法当然是，拥有稍微多一些的姓卡彭特（Carpenter，意为木匠）的木匠的原因是，卡彭特这个名字很可能起源于从事木工的家庭。因此，某种祖先与职业的联系推动了名字的选择和职业的选择。很有可能，但如果你进行计算，你很快就会发现这只占极小比例的人口。因此，假设即使经过了10代人，
there's a 50% chance that you did what your dad did and a 50% chance that he did what his grandfather did, which is probably higher than reality, you're talking about a probability of less than one in a thousand already over 10 generations. In other words, surnames are so old and they change hands. You know, when a woman named Carpenter mayors account name Farmer, for example, that that's really, it really just can't account for an effect anywhere near this magnitude. Bread Palem is looked at large data sets and public records like the Social Security Death Index or State Marriage Records, databases with information about millions of Americans,
你有50%的概率做了你父亲做过的事，有50%的概率他做了他祖父做过的事，这可能比现实情况还要高，那么在10代人之后，这种概率已经小于千分之一了。换句话说，姓氏年代久远而且会发生转移。你知道，当一个叫卡彭特的女性嫁给一个叫农夫（Farmer）的人时，这真的、真的无法解释任何接近这种规模的效应。布雷特·佩勒姆研究过大型数据集和公共记录，比如社会保障死亡指数或州结婚记录，这些数据库包含数百万美国人的信息，
and he and his fellow researchers have seen all kinds of funny effects. Like for example, one listener called in to say she and her husband were both born on the 25th day of different months. This isn't as uncommon as you might think. Beyond what you might expect by mere chance, there's about a 7% bias in that direction. So if you should have a thousand people doing that, you have a thousand seventy people doing that. If that doesn't sound like a lot, you're right.
他和他的研究人员同事们发现了各种有趣的效应。比如，有一位听众打电话来说，她和她的丈夫出生在不同月份的同一天25号。这其实并没有你想象的那么罕见。除了纯粹偶然所预期的之外，朝这个方向大约有7%的偏见。所以如果有1,000人这样做，就会有1,070人这样做。如果这听起来不算多，你是对的。
You should think of implicit ecotism as a tiny, invisible nudge. It won't shape what everyone does all the time, but it does shape what some people do some of the time. It's when you multiply these small effects over hundreds of millions of people that you start to see lots of examples. Bread says that if you really love your birthday, the effect gets even larger. Our operational definition of really loving your birthday was getting married on your birthday number. So if you got married on the 13th of the month, you were quite a bit more likely to marry
你应该把内隐自负看作是一种微小、无形的轻微推力。它不会时刻塑造每个人的行为，但它确实会在某些时候塑造某些人的行为。当你把这些微小的效应乘以数亿人时，你就会开始看到大量的例子。布雷特说，如果你真的很喜欢你的生日，这种效应会变得更大。我们对“真正喜欢你的生日”的操作性定义是在你的生日数字那天结婚。所以如果你在每月的13号结婚，你更有可能与
another person who also had the number 13 as his birthday number. Again, Brett calls this an implicit bias for a reason. You may not be consciously choosing things as important as your spouse or your profession or the place you call home based on arbitrary factors like your name or your birthday. He thinks the bias comes about simply because we like our names in our birthdays and have positive associations with them. And so you just associate your name
另一个同样将数字13作为生日数字的人结婚。再说一次，布雷特称这为内隐偏见是有原因的。你可能不会有意识地根据诸如你的名字或生日等任意因素来选择像你的配偶、你的职业或你称之为家的地方这样重要的事情。他认为这种偏见的产生仅仅是因为我们喜欢自己的名字和生日，并且对它们有积极的联想。所以你自然会把你的名字
with all the wonderful things that come along with that. And the best bit of evidence I have that I've never bothered to publish is there's one part of people's names they don't like that much and that's their middle names. You know, and the joke about that is the sole purpose of a child's middle name is to know when he's really in trouble. And my additional comment is to know if he might be a serial killer someday, right? So the middle name is not nearly as loved as the first or the last name.
与随之而来的所有美好事物联系起来。我掌握的最好且从没费心发表的证据是，人们对自己名字中有一部分其实没那么喜欢，那就是中间名。你知道的，关于这个的一个笑话是，孩子中间名的唯一作用就是让人知道他什么时候真的惹上麻烦了。我的补充评论是，好知道他以后会不会成为连环杀手，对吧？所以中间名远不像名或姓那样受人喜爱。
People feel very ambivalent about their middle name. They can be other reasons for ambivalence. Sometimes we dislike it when another person has the same birthday. If you were born on April 20th, you might hate the fact Hitler was born on that day too. Brett finds that if a consumer product happens to have your name on it but is poorly built, you are more likely to hate that product. People dislike seeing something inferior in the world that has their name on it.
人们对自己的中间名感觉非常矛盾。产生矛盾的原因也可能各不相同。有时，当另一个人有相同的生日时，我们会感到不喜欢。如果你出生在4月20日，你可能会讨厌希特勒也是在那天出生这一事实。布雷特发现，如果某种消费品恰好带有你的名字，但做工粗糙，你更有可能会讨厌该产品。人们讨厌看到世界上出现带有自己名字的劣质东西。
The New York Times As Brad and I were talking, I realized something a little uncomfortable, that I myself had fallen prey to implicit ecotism. You know, as you're talking right now, I'm realizing something about myself for the very first time. There is, there was a philosopher in India whose name was Shankara, my name, and he actually taught a philosophy that is known as Vedanta.
《纽约时报》 正当布雷特和我交谈时，我意识到了一件有点不舒服的事，那就是我自己也成了内隐自负的受害者。你知道，就在你刚才说话的时候，我生平第一次意识到了关于我自己的某些事情。在印度曾有一位哲学家名叫商羯罗（Shankara），和我的名字一样，他实际上传授了一种被称为“吠檀多”（Vedanta）的哲学。
And I've always been drawn to the fact that I find the philosophy of Vedanta to be very interesting and the fact that Shankara taught that philosophy, I thought was just charming, but now as I'm listening to you say this, I'm realizing that this could just be implicit equities. I've read his work very well and it truly is wonderful. It's brilliant. So I think in this case,
我一直被这样一个事实吸引：我发现吠檀多的哲学非常有趣，而商羯罗传授了这种哲学这一事实，我认为简直妙不可言，但现在当我听你这么说时，我意识到这可能只是一种内隐自负。我读过他的作品，而且它确实非常棒。它太才华横溢了。所以我想在这种情况下，
you make the objectively good decision. At the same time, it does make you think though. Absolutely, yes. Has this ever happened to you, Brett? Do you ever think about yourself and how the obesity and autism is affecting you? We're getting a little personal here, but I can't resist being a little bit personal.
你做出了客观上明智的决定。与此同时，这确实也引发了你的思考。绝对是的。布雷特，这种事发生在你身上过吗？你有没有想过你自己，以及肥胖和自闭症是如何影响你的？我们这里讨论得有点私人化了，但我忍不住要稍微私人化一点。
I would say that probably the most dramatic example is that my son Matthew, his last name is Poland. His mother's last name was Poland, my last name is Pelham. And I entered a relationship with her before I developed this theory, not after I developed the theory to validate the theory. So, you're a Pelham, and you got into a relationship with the woman named Poland.
我想说，最戏剧性的例子可能就是我的儿子马修（Matthew），他的姓是波兰（Poland）。他母亲的姓是波兰，我的姓是佩勒姆（Pelham）。我在提出这个理论之前就和她确立了恋爱关系，而不是为了验证这个理论才提出这个理论的。所以，你姓佩勒姆，却和一个叫波兰的女人谈恋爱。
Poland. And we are very different in most other ways. That's about as much as I'll say about that. Are you saying that the names played some kind of a role? I have to think it did. I have to think, and we were from different backgrounds, different religions. I mean, we come from very different worlds.
波兰。我们在大多数其他方面都非常不同。关于这一点我就说这么多了。你是说名字在其中起到了某种作用吗？我不得不认为它起作用了。我不得不认为，而且我们来自不同的背景，不同的宗教。我的意思是，我们来自非常不同的世界。
And yet, I was very attracted to her. So where she was attracted to me, right? Yeah. So I understand why you would sort of call this charming. And I think if you do this work for a while, there is a certain smile that comes to your face as you sort of look at these connections and you sort of see, you understand
然而，我还是深深地被她吸引了。所以她也被我吸引了，对吧？是的。所以我也理解为什么你有时会觉得这很迷人。而且我认为，如果你从事这项工作一段时间，当你回顾这些联系并看到、理解
sort of the choices that human beings make. But I do think there's something disturbing about it because I think there is a very strong sense that I think most of us have. I have the sense, even though I've been covering the world of the unconscious mind for the last 10 years, I have the sense that my choices are deliberate choices, that I've thought about them.
人类所做出的种种选择时，你的脸上会浮现出某种微笑。但我确实认为这其中有些令人不安的地方，因为我认为我们大多数人心中都有一种非常强烈的直觉。我有这种感觉，尽管在过去的10年里我一直在报道无意识思维的世界，但我仍然觉得我的选择是深思熟虑的选择，是我思考过的。
I've actually, I'm making them intentionally. And the idea that you're coming in and telling me that they're these hidden factors that come in and change how I think about myself, it is a disturbing idea. It is a little bit disturbing. And of course, most people do what you and I do, which is say, well, of course that applies to the rest of the world, but I, in particular, would never fall prey to implicit racial bias or implicit egotism. So most of us do tend to sort of separate ourselves from even our own findings, but I've
实际上，我是有意做出这些选择的。而你却来告诉我，有一些隐藏的因素介入并改变了我对自己的看法，这个想法确实让人不安。这确实有点让人不安。当然，大多数人都做着你和我一样的事，那就是说：嗯，这当然适用于世界上其他人，但我这个人，绝对不会成为内隐种族偏见或内隐自负的受害者。所以我们大多数人确实倾向于把自己与甚至是我们自己的研究结果隔离开来，但我
become in the past decade or so comfortable enough with the study that I have to admit that I really never know for sure exactly why I did something. I mean, sometimes I have a pretty good idea, but I certainly don't kid myself anymore to say that I even usually know why I do what I do. I mean, there's just too much research, much of which you documented and reported on, that shows that biases were completely unaware of, nudges, sometimes powerfully drive us in very particular directions. So, I think I've just kind of let go of it. It was disturbing to me when I first began studying it, disturbing as well as delightful, and now it's become more delightful
在过去十年左右的时间里，对这项研究已经熟悉到足以承认，我真的从来无法确切知道我为什么要做出某事。我的意思是，有时我有一个相当不错的想法，但我肯定不再自欺欺人地说我通常知道自己为什么要这么做。我的意思是，有太多的研究——其中许多你曾记录和报道过——表明那些我们完全没有意识到的偏见、那些微小的推力，有时会强有力地引导我们走向非常特定的方向。所以，我想我已经放下了这种心理障壁。当我刚开始研究它时，这让我感到不安，既不安又欣喜，而现在它变得更加令人欣喜，
unless disturbing. So perhaps you're wondering, how does any of this matter? Who cares if people born on the 23rd of September marry those born on the 23rd of July? Who cares if someone named Betsy Carpenter gravitates towards Carpentry? Why does it matter if I prefer a philosopher whose name is similar to my own? It at least raises tough questions about the degree to which we
而少了几分不安。所以你也许会想，这到底有什么关系？谁在乎9月23日出生的人是否和7月23日出生的人结婚？谁在乎一个叫贝茜·卡彭特的人是否倾向于从事木工？如果我更喜欢一个名字与我相似的哲学家，这又有什么关系呢？它至少提出了一个艰难的问题，即我们拥有
have free will. So I think some people who have pretty negative reactions to this work are very threatened by it in the sense that it suggests that very important decisions have at least a little nudging influence based on things that you're completely unaware of. So if people are more likely than they should be by chance to marry another person who happens to share their birthday number, that's not an objectively great reason to get married. You should get married because you share values. You're both Republicans. You're both rabid Marxists.
自由意志的程度究竟有多少。因此，我认为有些对这项工作反应相当消极的人对它感到非常威胁，因为它暗示了那些非常重要的决定，至少受到了一点点来自你完全无意识的事物的推动影响。因此，如果人们比纯粹偶然情况下更有可能与另一个恰好拥有相同生日数字的人结婚，这并不是客观上结婚的极佳理由。你们结婚应该是因为你们有共同的价值观。你们都是共和党人。你们都是狂热的马克思主义者。
But learning that these subtle little influences can affect what you do, apparently to some people, I find it delightful. But some people find it pretty threatening. I don't think that it proves that there's no such thing as free will. But to me, it does suggest that we don't always have free will. Sometimes we make a decision for one reason that we told ourselves when really the more powerful underlying reason is something we could have never put our fingers on. And this isn't just a matter of being drawn to someone who shares your birthday.
但是得知这些微妙的小影响会影响你的行为，显然对某些人来说——我发现这很令人愉快。但有些人觉得这相当具有威胁性。我不认为这证明了自由意志不存在。但在我看来，这确实表明我们并不总是有自由意志。有时我们出于某种原因做出决定，并这样告诉自己，而实际上更强大的潜在原因是我们根本无法察觉的。这不仅限于被与你共享生日的人吸引，
In general, we tend to prefer things and people who have something to do with us. And that can be a big problem. Absolutely. I do a little bit of research on social justice, and that's one of the things that concerns me most, is that we tend to focus on people who are more like us, who speak our language, who speak our idiom, who look like us, who worship like us, and we pay much less attention,
总的来说，我们往往更喜欢与我们有关的事物和人。这可能会成为一个大问题。绝对是的。我做过一些关于社会正义的研究，这也是最让我担忧的事情之一，那就是我们往往把注意力集中在那些更像我们的人身上，他们说我们的语言，说我们的方言，看起来像我们，像我们一样崇拜，而不幸的是，我们对那些并非如此的人的问题关注得要少得多，
sadly, to the problems of people who don't. On the other hand, I think this finding, like any finding in psychology or behavioral economics, can be used for good or evil, and the way it works in the world can be used for good or bad. And so a great example that I perceive as at least a cousin of implicit digitism is a study I think was done by Elliot Smith and colleagues about ten years ago. He looked at implicit racial bias, and he looked at implicit racial bias as a function, a whether a person from a different ethnic group,
另一方面，我认为这一发现，就像心理学或行为经济学中的任何发现一样，可以用于善，也可以用于恶，它在世界上运作的方式也可以是好的或坏的。所以我认为至少是内隐自负的表亲的一个很好的例子是，埃利奥特·史密斯（Elliot Smith）及其同事在大约十年前做的一项研究。他研究了内隐种族偏见，他将内隐种族偏见视为一种函数——看一个来自不同族裔群体的人（
I think he had whites in African-Americans, for example, had simply given you a gentle, friendly touch on the shoulder. And if they had given you a friendly general, hello, how are you touch, that reduced their implicit racial bias. So to me, when another person becomes a part of you, in a very tiny way, you play in
我想他研究的对象例如有白人和非裔美国人）是否只是在你的肩膀上轻轻地、友好地拍了一下。如果他们给过你一个友好的、一般的、问候式的“你好，你好吗”的触摸，这就会减少他们的内隐种族偏见。因此对我来说，当另个人成为你的一部分时，以一种非常微小的方式，你和这个人一起打
Trimiel basketball with this person, and you didn't like his group, but now that you meet him, and he's on your team, suddenly he becomes a part of you. His group becomes a part of you, and your stereotypes get softened and diminished a little bit. If you can fall in love with your name or your birthday, can't you also fall in love with your own ideas, your own work? Of course you can. Researchers call this the IKEA effect.
三人篮球，而你本来不喜欢他的群体，但现在你遇到了他，他成为了你团队的一员，突然间他成为了你的一部分。他的群体成为了你的一部分，你的刻板印象也随之变得温和并稍微减少了一些。如果你能爱上你的名字或你的生日，难道你不能也爱上你自己的想法、你自己的工作吗？你当然可以。研究人员称这种现象为“宜家效应”。
Imagine that you built a table. This is Tulane University Marketing Professor Daniel Mochon. Maybe came out a little bit crooked. Probably your wife or your neighbor would see it for what it is, probably a shoddy piece of workmanship. A shoddy piece of workmanship, because some of us are not necessarily talented at building our own furniture. In fact, if you go online, you can find plenty of videos
想象一下，你造了一张桌子。这是杜兰大学营销学教授丹尼尔·莫雄（Daniel Mochon）。也许做出来有点歪。可能你的妻子或邻居会看出它的本来面目，大概是一件做工粗糙的手工制品。一件做工粗糙的手工制品，因为我们中的一些人并不一定擅长自己制作家具。事实上，如果你上网，你可以找到大量视频，
of people struggling to put together their IKEA coffee table or dress up. I don't really understand what this part is. I don't feel like we have those pieces. We thought we did some of that. But even though building the furniture can be a painful chore, people seem to really like the outcome. Sometimes you think you're doing it wrong,
人们在费力地组装他们的宜家咖啡桌或梳妆台。我其实不太明白这一部分是什么。我觉得我们没有那些片段。我们以为我们做过其中的一部分。但尽管组装家具可能是一件痛苦的杂务，人们似乎真的很喜欢这个结果。有时你以为你做错了，
but at the end of the day, you built a task together. You do. You do. You do. To you, that table might seem really great, because you're the one who created it. It is the fruit of your labor, and that is really the idea behind the A key effect. It is that we come to overvalue the things that we have created ourselves. In fact, the psychological bias might actually be an important part of IKEA's business model.
但到了最后，你们一起完成了一件任务。确实如此。确实如此。确实如此。对你而言，那张桌子可能看起来非常棒，因为你是创造它的人。这是你劳动的果实，这其实就是宜家效应背后的理念。也就是说，我们最终会过度评价我们自己创造的东西。事实上，这种心理偏见实际上可能是宜家商业模式的重要组成部分。
The way people usually think about IKEA is that IKEA gives you good furniture for low cost because they offload lots of the costs onto their consumers, the assembly costs. But in fact, we're in a sense challenging that idea and saying that this is actually a psychological benefit behind this, that actually people might end up liking their furniture more because they built it. And so it's not so much a cost but a benefit that they get to build their own furniture. Daniel and his co-authors did a series of experiments to test this hypothesis. They brought volunteers into the lab and gave them either a Lego car pre-assembled or gave
人们通常对宜家的看法是，宜家以低成本为你提供优质家具，因为他们将大量的成本——组装成本——转嫁给了消费者。但事实上，我们在某种程度上对这一观点提出了质疑，并表示这背后实际上存在着一种心理上的好处，即人们可能最终会更喜欢他们的家具，因为是他们自己组装的。因此，这与其说是一种成本，不如说是他们自己组装家具所获得的一种好处。丹尼尔和他的合著者做了一系列实验来检验这一假设。他们把志愿者带到实验室，给他们一个预先组装好的乐高汽车，或者给
them Legos and instructions and told the participants to build a car themselves. Then they asked the volunteers, how much would you pay to keep your Lego car? And what we find is that the people who build their own Legos, not only are willing to pay more to keep their assembled Legos, but also when we ask them how proud they are of their own creations, they tend to be prouder of their Legos. In mind, these are Legos that are designed to 5 to 7 year olds, but nonetheless, it seems to be some competence and some pride associated with one's creation, even for basic things as building Legos. The researchers replicated the study using other products, like IKEA furniture,
他们乐高积木和说明书，并告诉参与者自己组装一辆车。然后他们问志愿者：你愿意花多少钱买下并保留你的乐高汽车？我们发现，那些自己组装乐高积木的人，不仅愿意花更多的钱来保留他们组装好的乐高积木，而且当我们问他们对自己创造的成果有多骄傲时，他们往往对自己的乐高积木感到更骄傲。请记住，这些是专为5到7岁儿童设计的乐高积木，但尽管如此，即使是对于拼乐高这样基础的事情，似乎也存在着某种与个人创造相关联的胜任感和自豪感。研究人员使用其他产品（如宜家家具）复制了这项研究，
and the effect was the same. People who spent time and effort building something felt proud of what they'd built, fell in love with it, and were willing to pay lots of money to keep the things they'd built. From the perspective of a rational economist, this doesn't make much sense. The students might be willing to pay twice as much money to buy the exact same Lego car. If they just finished building that Lego car, then if the Lego car was given to them pre-built. So why might people value something more after building it themselves compared to buying the same product made by someone else for half the cost. Our hypothesis was that people tend to use products to signal value and identities
结果是一样的。花时间和精力组装某物的人会对他们建造的东西感到自豪，爱上它，并愿意花大笔钱来保留他们建造的东西。从理性经济学家的角度来看，这没有什么意义。学生们可能愿意花两倍的钱来购买完全相同的乐高汽车，如果他们刚刚完成了那辆乐高汽车的组装，相比于直接把预先组装好的乐高汽车送给他们。那么，为什么人们在自己动手组装后，会比花半价购买别人做好的同款产品，对某物赋予更高的价值呢？我们的假设是，人们倾向于利用产品向自己和他人
to both themselves and to others. And we know that an identity that people really care about is showing that they're competent and this is sort of one of the basics of human motivation. And so we hypothesize that people use self-made products as a way to signal competence to both themselves and to others. You know, having just built a table or having just built a bookcase, that bookcase has completed products, acts in a sense of a badge of my own personal competence. I completed it, therefore I know I'm a competent person.
传达价值和身份认同。我们知道，人们非常关心的一个身份认同就是展示他们是有能力的，这也是人类动机的基本点之一。因此，我们假设人们将自制的产品作为一种向自己和他人发出胜任感信号的方式。你知道，刚刚造好一张桌子或者刚刚建好一个书柜，那个书柜作为一个完整的产品，在某种意义上充当了我个人胜任感的一个徽章。我完成了它，因此我知道我是一个有能力的人。
And more I can display this product and signal that identity, this competent identity to others. And so we hypothesized that it was these feelings of competence associated with the products that led to their increasing valuation. To test the theory that people's feelings of competence was behind the IKEA effect, the researchers had some participants think about other qualities they might value in themselves besides competence, things like honesty or intelligence or humor. Basically the idea was, if we make it less important for people to demonstrate competence, do they still overvalue their own creations? So we found that the key effect disappeared when we did that manipulation. So once competence wasn't that important to people, people, our participants no longer seem to get much
而且我更可以展示这个产品，并向他人发出这种身份信号，这种有能力的身份信号。因此我们假设，正是与产品相关的这种胜任感导致了它们价值的提升。为了验证“人们的胜任感是宜家效应背后的原因”这一理论，研究人员让一些参与者思考除了胜任感之外，他们可能会在自己身上看重的其他品质，比如诚实、智慧或幽默。基本上这个想法是，如果我们降低人们展示胜任感的重要性，他们还会不会过度评价自己的创造？因此我们发现，当我们进行这种操纵时，宜家效应消失了。因此，一旦胜任感对人们来说不再那么重要，人们、我们的参与者似乎就不再从创造他们自己的产品中获得太多
value of creating their own products. Again, suggesting that the reason why we tend to like our own creations is because we use them as a way to signal competence both to ourselves and to others. Here is the flip side of that coin. You can make the IKEA effects stronger by getting people to question their competence. In one experiment, Daniel and his colleagues gave participants math problems to solve before asking them to build an IKEA project. If the problems were difficult, lots of people failed to solve them. Now, volunteers became much more likely to want to demonstrate
价值了。这再次表明，我们往往喜欢自己创造的东西的原因，是因为我们用它们作为向自己和他人发出胜任感信号的一种方式。这里是硬币的另一面。你可以通过让人对自己的胜任感产生质疑来增强宜家效应。在一个实验中，丹尼尔和他的同事在要求参与者组装宜家项目之前，让他们解答数学问题。如果问题很难，许多人都无法解出。此时，志愿者变得更有可能想要通过
their competence through the IKEA building project. The participants who at least temporarily had their sense of competence threatened who got a very difficult math questions tended to be more willing to build their own products. So when we survey them and ask them, would you prefer to have an IKEA product that comes pre-built or the exact same product that comes unbuilt and you would build it yourself. Those who got difficult math problems and were feeling someone incompetent at the time, seemed more willing, they were much more likely to want to build a product themselves. And therefore in a sense, restore their sense of competence through this activity. I mean, give me the number, Sarah,
宜家组装项目来展示他们的胜任感。那些至少在短时间内其胜任感受到威胁、遇到了非常困难的数学问题的参与者，往往更愿意自己动手组装产品。因此，当我们对他们进行调查并询问他们时：你更愿意拥有一个预先组装好的宜家产品，还是完全相同的、需要你自己动手组装的产品？那些遇到困难数学问题、当时觉得有些无能的参与者，似乎更愿意、更有可能想要自己动手组装产品。因此在某种程度上，通过这项活动恢复了他们的胜任感。我的意思是，告诉我具体数字，莎拉，
I mean, was this a big effect? Was this a small effect? I mean, what happens when people feel bad compared to when they don't feel bad? So what we found is that about a third of the people wanted to build the IKEA bookshelf in the control condition when they weren't made to feel bad. And this number went up to about 60% when they were made to feel bad. So significantly larger number of people wanted to do this. The IKEA effect and implicit ecotism might seem at first blush to be interesting and amusing, but not terribly significant. But the more I thought about this, the more I saw the potential implications. Just as we can be drawn to those who have the same birthday as us or the same name as us, we might also be more inclined to help people who look like us, or sound like us, or live
我的意思是，这是一个很大的影响吗？这是一个很小的影响吗？我的意思是，当人们感觉不好时，与他们感觉不坏时相比，情况会怎样？所以我们发现，在对照组中，当没有让他们感到不好时，大约有三分之一的人想要组装宜家的书架；而当让他们感到不好时，这个数字上升到了大约60%。因此，有明显更多的人想要这样做。宜家效应和内隐自负乍一看似乎有趣又好笑，但并非极其重要。但我想得越多，就越能看到潜在的意义。正如我们会被那些与我们生日相同或名字相同的人吸引一样，我们可能也更倾向于帮助那些长得像我们、
near us. Let's say you're a congressperson who's drafted a particular piece of legislation. Your commitment to that bill might outweigh its importance to the public. Well, let's say you're a president who starts a war. After years of investing your time and effort to prosecute that war, you may find it difficult to accept evidence that you made a mistake. It's fine to gaze lovingly in the mirror and to feel invested in our own ideas, but like Narcissus discovered himself, falling in love with our own reflection can come in great peril.
声音像我们或住在我们附近的人。假设你是一名起草了特定立法议案的国会议员。你对该法案的执着可能会超过它对公众的重要性。或者，假设你是一位发动战争的总统。经过多年投入时间和精力来推进这场战争，你可能会发现自己很难接受你犯了错的证据。充满爱意地凝视镜子并投资于我们自己的想法并没有错，但正如纳西索斯（Narcissus）自己所发现的那样，爱上我们自己的倒影会带来巨大的危险。
Hidden Brain is produced by Tara Boyle, Raina Cohen, Renee Clark, Maggie Penman, Lucy Perkins, Jenny Schmidt and Barthas Shah. If you like the show, check out our weekly podcast, search for Hidden Brain on iTunes, NPR1 or wherever you listen to podcasts. You can also follow the show on Facebook, Twitter and Instagram and listen for my stories each week during morning edition on your local public radio station. I'm Shankar Vitaanthan and this is NPR. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
《隐藏的大脑》由塔拉·博伊尔（Tara Boyle）、雷娜·科恩（Raina Cohen）、雷妮·克拉克（Renee Clark）、玛吉·彭曼（Maggie Penman）、露西·帕金斯（Lucy Perkins）、珍妮·施密特（Jenny Schmidt）和巴塔斯·沙阿（Barthas Shah）制作。如果你喜欢这个节目，请查看我们的每周播客，在iTunes、NPR1或你收听播客的任何地方搜索“Hidden Brain”。你还可以在Facebook、Twitter和Instagram上关注本节目，并在每周的《早间新闻》（Morning Edition）节目中收听我在你当地公共广播电台播出的故事。我是尚卡尔·维丹坦（Shankar Vedantam），这里是美国国家公共电台（NPR）。这个剧集还没有评论。点击抄本中的任意句子即可发表评论。